I'm already not like wow I got it I got
it mr. clock the house easel someone's
looking us in its the rooms
odds are they don't get out in time for
two months Benji reality first your mind
must be in order must be in order
I am the stone finest stone
you better check your drawers Sebastian
Sebastian take your pants off - wait a
minute like maybe this one yeah so this
is so Corrales in society all right
you're gonna see all day here I've just
found another one there you go Spain
time is ticking
hello that's what I was gonna do yeah
okay call for help
hold on not too much friends powers a so
that's the combination yeah of course
sorry number three nine one five three
two one go
[Music]
what's the address of your apartment
strange
you don't remember they shot that three
years three nine one five this is what I
do that is something can do you know
we got I think I think i'ma wait wait
back up
[Music]
oh don't even read it come on let the
movies be your guide read this read
battle it all right you don't yet have
the time so beware of all the tricks but
if you crack the code with three are you
just like a hype man in my reading with
three three and we have to put the
movies in order Mac here holding the
decoder yeah I'm trying to figure it out
bro three six two nine that has to be it
three six two and I
[Music]
[Applause]
you're not done yet what
come on Syria it gets weirder
what that what it is all about so just
be ready
listen to the good dr. Daniels right
part of the hands the way you see them
in the poster have you found all the
hands there's one more man 30 seconds
[Music]
Nerys
[Music]